amongst the entirety of his nation and
followers for generations after him.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala describes
Ibraim
he says
he says Ibraim
indeed was an
that's a very very curious
choice of words
what does mean here in this verse in
this context. Indeed, Ibraim was an
ummah.
Well, in this context means im.
He was an imam. He was one worthy of
following.
He was one who is a role model for all
men and women that followed and came
after him. And as such he is coined and
referred to as the father of the
prophets
because he was so beloved to Allah and
his
example
was of such high caliber
and his example
was such a paragon for the best that
humanity
is potential of
that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
designated his lineage and his offspring
to be the only lineage that would
contain prophethood and revelation after
him. He is the father of the prophets.
Meaning no prophet or messenger after
Ibraim
is from any other lineage. All prophets
and messengers come from his lineage.
And Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala commands
the prophet Muhammad Sam. Wasallam and
hismah to follow the way of Ibraim.
But the word umah here
also means nation and that's how it's
used in the Quran.
Meaning that Ibraim
was of such high caliber.
He had traits
that were so incredible
that it would take an entire nation
collectively
to find all of the traits found in
Ibraimisam.
You have an entire nation of people on
one hand and you have Ibraimis
on the other.
Yet this wasn't even the best of
humanity yet.
The best was still to come.
And then our prophet Muhammad
sallall.aii wasallam
in a rather obscure and tiny cave on an
evening of Ramadan
is there contemplating
himself, contemplating Allah,
contemplating the creation and the
cosmos.
And an angel comes to him with the
message of
and the rest as they say was history.
Our prophet Muhammad sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam was sent.
And
not only did he embody the teachings of
his forefather and messenger Ibraimis,
but he would later become the envy of
all prophets and messengers after him.
And his nation would become the envy of
all nations before them. And his book
would become the envy of all books
revealed
before
our prophet Muhammad Sam. Wasam.
He was sent by Allah Subhanahu Waaala
with the Quran.
And the Quran is an incredible miracle
that cannot just be explained away.
There's no amount of explaining,
debating,
no amount of excuses,
no amount of astronomical
chances and anomaly
can explain the Quran
other than it being the words of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala as revealed to his
messenger. That is the only explanation.
Any other explanation of the Quran
raises far more questions than it does
give us answers.
And likewise, Allah Subhanahu Wa Ta'ala
draws our attention constantly
throughout the Quran that it doesn't end
there.
It's not just the miracle of the Quran
but the one who came bearing that Quran
[Arabic recitation]
If I
was an ummah our prophet Sam
was an umah. If I
was the close and dearest to Allah our
prophet sallall.aii Wasam
was the closest and dearest to Allah.
On the night of Israel
was elevated through the heavens one
after the other until he arrived at the
seventh heaven above the creation.
And he found Ibraimis
there
with his back leaning on alm,
the equivalent of the Kaa on earth in
the heavens that the angels and
inhabitants of the heavens worship Allah
at.
And he found Ibraim.Isam am there and he
met him in person
and then he was raised past the level of
Ibraim
and he was brought before Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala
so close to Allah
our prophet was brought that he could
hear
the scribbling of the pens of
destiny
in the court of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala.
He could hear the scribbling of the pens
of destiny
writing you and I and writing all of the
creations destiny to come until the day
of judgment.
And our prophet sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam was sent back to the earth
and he led those prophets and messengers
in salah. Some scholars say
in
and amongst them Ibraim.
And he thus metaphorically took the
torch from all of the prophets before
him and the rest is as we know it to be.
Our prophet sallall.aii wasallam did not
reach this level very easily.
It's not something that was just handed
to him and given to him. Yes,
profitthood is something that you do not
earn. It is something that Allah creates
a person for. There's no amount of
worship or dutifulness that any of us
can exhibit to earn us profitthood, let
alone messengership.
However, the traits that the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam exhibited,
they are traits that he worked very hard
to hone
and they are traits that he worked very
very hard and diligently
to discipline himself to
because he was a human being
and as Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
commanded him to say
Say to them, I am but a human being who
receives revelation. A human being a as
you all are human beings.
And as all human beings have to fight
themselves and to fight their nefs,
our prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam
had to fight
and he was not treated well or received
kindly by his people.
His very family, his very flesh and
blood turned against him.
Our prophet sallall.aii Wasam
yet in spite of these circumstances
exhibited a level of restraint, mercy,
forgiveness, and pardon.
A level of determination
that cannot be explained
by anything other than him being the
messenger of Allah. It's just not
possible.
We can
debate and chat and
our prophet sallall.aii wasallam's
enemies and antagonists and deniers till
this day can
argue and debate individual points and
write them off as anomalies
as coincidence.
However,
looking at the entirety of our prophet
sallall.aii wasallam's legacy
to explain
his existence and his life away as
anything short of a messenger
raises more questions than it does
provide answers.
If he was just a regular man
who brought this message and he just was
this altruist great guy that just really
wanted the best for people in spite of
himself. How did he achieve what he
achieved? How how is that possible?
How is it possible that we are still
speaking about this man 1,500
years later,
countless miles away from where he was,
you and I, we might as well have come
from another planet than the world he
existed in. Yet somehow
we're able to follow him. And he is
still mentioned to this day,
day and night.
Billions of people
designate their lives in pursuit of even
a portion of the virtue that our prophet
sallall.aii wasallam had.
As a matter of fact, not just the
entirety of his life, even one of his
descriptions,
his generosity,
his forgiveness, his mercy, his wisdom,
his insight,
his courage, any one of these,
how could someone that is not a divine
me, that is not a divinely guided and
inspired messenger of Allah achieve any
of these things.
Our prophet sallall.aii wasallam brought
this message
to humanity.
He brought this message starting with
the people of Mecca
and he recited to them the verses of
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
and they began to antagonize him. They
began to berate him. They insulted him.
Anyone who was associated with him was
automatically in mortal danger.
And he endured humiliations
that
collectively
perhaps we have not endured.
Collectively
our prophet sallall.aii Wasam
was faced with such antagonist
that for instancebu's
stepfatherbu
was seen by Abu Jah sitting in a
gathering listening to the Quran from
the prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam
and he was lifelong friends with Abu
Jah.
They were very close two peas in a pod,
childhood friends and they were the st
superstars of
and when he later saw Okbah Abu Jah said
I am very very stunned. I'm just shocked
by your behavior
was one of the leadership of Quraysh.
How could you sit and listen to that
man? I'm upset with you. Don't speak to
me.
And so said, "Listen, just anything.
Tell me what to do
to regain your trust and your respect."
He said, "Nothing short of going to that
same gathering tomorrow. I want you to
spit right in his face in front of
everyone.
And so went the next day sat in front of
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam and as
he was reciting the Quran to him he spit
right in his face.
How many of us have even had that happen
in our personal lives over much sillier
things
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
endured.
He is making salah at the
and
brought
the
endrails
of a camel. the endrails, you know, the
things that you throw away, the guts and
the
the hide of a slaughtered camel. And as
the prophet sallallah.aii wasallam was
in sujud in front of the Kaa,
he came and brought those endrails and
dumped them all over his back sam.
And he had no choice but to remain in
Sud until his daughter
realized what was happening and came and
took these things, this garbage, this
carcass off of our prophet's backben
was the keyeper, the gatekeeper of the
Ka.
this tribe of Iben Shabba, they were the
ones who had the key to the Cabba
because the
Cabba's upkeep was distributed amongst
the tribes of Quraysh
and his tribe. They were honored with
the key of the Kaa and every week or so
they would go and open the door to the
Cabba so that people could come in and
see the Cabba, etc.
And when Ibala would come and open the
door, people would line up to go inside
and see the Kaa. Who has more right to
enter the house
of Allah built by Ibraim
than our prophet Muhammad sallall.aii
wasallam.
And as he lines up with the likes of all
of these other terrible human beings
to enter into the Kaa and to see it as
he goes to enter in his turn in line
says, "No, not you."
And he insults him and berates him in
front of everyone and turns him away.
Get out of here. You're not welcome here
into the house of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala.
They were
resorted to the of for 2 years.
Not just the prophet Muhammad Sam
and the Muslim.
anyone even slightly affiliated with him
or his tribe or the twin tribes of
Benihashim.
They were resorted and kicked out of
Mecca to the valley of Abalib
and they remained there for 2 years not
being able to purchase a grain
of sustenance from any of the tribes in
the Arab Peninsula. Some of them died of
hunger. It said that the whailing of
women and children
from that wretched valley,
the whales of hunger could be heard for
miles at night from where that was. This
is what he endured. Sallallah.aii
wasallam. A small amount of what he
endured.
And so what would you do
if just a few years later you stood in
the doorway of the Cabba with the key of
the Cabba in your hand. And all of those
men and women that did these things to
you and your family and your followers
stood at your feet and at your mercy in
the conquest of Mecca. What would you
do? Would you at least be a little bit
upset about these things? Would you at
least have an axe to grind?
Our prophet Sam
came to the Kaa
requested the key from Iba in the
conquest of Mecca in the seventh year
after Hijra. He returned in the iron the
iron battalion amongst his companions.
He went into the the cabba. Its doors
were opened and you know the Cabba is
high up. The people gathered underneath
him and he said, "What do you think I'm
going to do to you all now?
Today's the day. What do you expect?"
Of course, their response was what?
Karim,
we expect only the best from you. You're
such an honorable man.
I wasn't honorable. 10 years ago, that
was a very different song in a very
different tune that you're singing
today.
As the swords hang over your necks, very
interesting.
What do you expect me to do? He said,
[Silence]
He said, "I will say no more to you than
Ysef said to his brothers.
I will not blame you
today and I ask Allah to forgive you
all. You're all free to go. And just
that, it was gone.
Not one human being who is not following
the message of Allah, the inspiration,
the revelation of Allah can muster up
that amount
of mercy and forgiveness. He doesn't
exist. That person, you've never met
him. As a matter of fact, you've never
met a collection of people that could
muster up that level of forgiveness.
And so when you learn these things, you
look at yourself,
you start to feel very, very small when
you think of the grievances that you
have with others.
So and so said this about me. So and so
said this, he didn't say this. So and so
looked at me funny 10 years ago. So and
so he said something bad about me behind
my back and I just can't forgive him
today.
This is your prophetam.
[Silence]
[Arabic recitation]
And I will say one word before we end
and that is that often times we wish to
celebrate the prophet sallallahu alaihi
Wasam. This is how we celebrate him. How
do we celebrate him? Is it by throwing
parties? We celebrate him by learning
these things about him and demanding
at least a portion of this from our own
selves.
me. I shall
I shetter
[Silence]
for
Allahbar.
All
[Silence]
stand shouldertosh shoulder. Align your
shoulders and your feet with the
shoulders and feet of your two neighbors
on either side of you. Please double
check your phones. Ensure that they are
silent.
Jeez.
Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Amen.
Lord.
Foreign
speech. Foreign speech. Foreign speech.
for
[Silence]
Allahel.
All
behind us.
I'm a dimension.
All
I
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
for
[Silence]
a
Fore!
Foreign! Foreign!
for
him.
I am
Allah.
me
down.
long.
[Silence]
Allah
A long
act.
[Silence]
That's
brothers and sisters. Asalamu alalaykum.
I just wanted to share sad news. , as
you may already know, we lost our
brother, young brother, 29 years old
Ali Jalani
in the accident during the past week.
May Allah grant patience to his family
and grant him ja. Amen.
Brothers and sisters, I also want to
share with you some very good news for
the community.
Alhamdulillah,
Rahma Academy has achieved a very
significant milestone.
We now have enrollment of 100 students
at the Rahama Academy. Takir
[Arabic recitation]
academy is offering up to five fifth
grade. So if anybody has a child in that
age bracket and they can benefit from
it, please consult with brother Ahmed
Jabber
and or myself and we'll see what we can
do to accommodate any of the questions
that you have.
Brothers,